Peggy 18 Tamriel is a living persistent
world populated with hundreds of
memorable stories and characters but the
most unforgettable experiences are not
scripted they're shaped by your
experience playing with others the Elder
Scrolls online Tamriel unlimited is a
multiplayer role-playing game that
offers players many ways to interact
with friends both old and new
the world is embroiled in a bitter war
of alliances three factions vie for
domination over all of Tamriel where you
place your allegiance is of the utmost
importance
whichever faction you enter war is
inevitable take part in massive battles
alongside hundreds of other players in
Serie Dell builds siege weapons like
trebuchet z' to level enemy keeps or
defend your faction strongholds from
other alliances work cooperatively with
your alliance to claim the victory which
is rightfully yours
venture into shared public dungeons
where you will be joined by other
adventurers who will fight by your side
take on epic world challenges such as
dark angers and massive bosses that are
best tackled with a group you'll also
have the opportunity to join up to five
guilds or create one yourself and
recruit other players to join you on
your adventures communicate using
built-in voice chat that makes it simple
coordinating with other players chat
with others to plot your next Alliance
battle initiate trades of crafted goods
or just keep in touch assemble a team of
four to explore vast dungeons scattered
throughout the lands venture deep within
to learn the secrets of Tamriel and
discover untold riches
no matter the level disparity between
you and your groupmates content will
scale to your party when your character
reaches level 15 you attained veteran
status veterans can test their skills on
even more difficult challenges such as
the high level adventure zone craglorn
or the exciting dragon star arena for an
even bigger challenge join a team of 12
to engage in trials mode where your
group will face waves of enemies and
colossal bosses competing for loot and
leaderboard ranks the multiplayer
aspects of the Elder Scrolls online
Tamriel unlimited created deeper more
fulfilling experience for every player
in Tamriel the bonds forged in-game
build true camaraderie Tamriel unlimited
boasts a vibrant active community that
is the heart and soul of the online
experience so grab a friend or hail a
passing stranger in town and let the
adventure begin